So before we go into how predication works
in hardware, let's first look at the technique called
if-conversion, which is how the compiler creates the
code that will be executed along both paths. So
let's say we have a relatively small if-then-else
here, where depending on the condition, x gets either
the value from array of i, or array
from j, and y gets either incremented or decremented.
If-conversion, transforms this code into the work of
both paths, followed by a selection of some sort,
between the results of the two paths. But there
is still a question of how do we do
this. If we convert this into some sort
of a conditional expression that still branches based on
the condition and then does the move of x2
into x, otherwise, does the move of x into
x1, then we really haven't done much. Because we
converted one branch into another branch and now we
have this branch twice. So unless we have some
sort of a correlating predictor like, for example, the
global history predictor, we will possibly have two missed
predictions here. Instead of the one we might have
had. So if this is all you can do,
then you don't do if-conversion. What we need for if-conversion
to work is some sort of a move instruction that will
do something like move x1 into x, if a flag is true.